الولايات المتحده ان قواتها شنت غاره جويه
استهدفت منشاه تابعه لما سمتها جماعات
مرتبطه بالحرس الثوري الايراني في سوريا
مساء امس الخميس واوضحت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن امر
بتنفيذ الهجوم ردا على مقتل متعاقد امريكي
وجرح اخر واصابه خمسه جنود امريكيين في
هجوم بمسيره وقع في وقت سابق على قاعده
للتحالف قرب الحسكه شمال شرق سوريا من جهه
افادت مواقع اعلاميه مواليه لنظام السوري
بان قصفا بالطيران استهدف مركز التنميه
الريفيه ومركز الحبوب في مدينه دير الزور
والذي تتمركز فيه مجموعه عسكريه مدعومه من
ايران ما اسفر عنه وقوع اصابه
[موسيقى]
الهجوم الامريكي الذي اعلنه البنتاغون هو
واحد من سلسله هجمات وغارات مضاده وقعت
بين الجانب الامريكي والمجموعات المدعومه
من ايران في سوريا ويقول مسؤولون امريكيون
ان الجماعات المدعومه من ايران نفذت حوالي
ثمانيه وسبعين هجوما على قوات التحالف
بسوريا منذ عام 2021
وتنوعت وسائل الهجوم بين مسيرات ملغمه
وصواريخ وقذائف هاون في المقابل نفذت
اداره الرئيس بايدن ثلاثه غارات جويه في
وقت سابق ضد من نفذوا الهجمات المدعومه من
ايران وفق قولها وتنتشر القواعد والمراكز
التي توجد فيها قوات امريكيه في سوريا
بمناطق جنوب شرق سوريا حيث اقيمت قاعده
التنف وكذلك الى الشمال الشرقي من سوريا
وتحديدا قرب الحسكه ودير الزور حيث
المناطق الغنيه بالنفط التقديرات
الامريكيه المتداوله تشير على وجود ما بين
900 الى 2000 جندي امريكي في شريط يبلغ
طوله نحو 55 كم
ولينا من ادلب مراسلنا ادهم ابو حسام ادهم
هل من معطيات توضح ما الذي جرى
يعني عاده ما يكون هناك ضربات جويه
امريكيه اما بطيران مسير او عبر طائرات اف
16 بعد كل استهداف من قبل ما تعرف بالحرس
الثوري الايراني التي تتمركز في عده مواقع
على طول الحدود السوريه العراقيه عندما
تستهدف هذه القوات
قواعد امريكيه او حتى قواعد
لتحالف امريكي كقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
عاده ما يكون هناك استهداف
لمعابر معبر القائمه الحدودي مع العراق او
مواقع تتمركز فيها قوات مواليه لايران
الاستهداف ليله امس كان لمركز الحبوب
وايضا مركز التنميه التي تتمركز فيها قوات
تابعه الحرس الثوري الايراني بحسب مصادر
للجزيره الاستهداف اسفر عن دمار كبير
واندلاع حرائق داخل المكان ولكن بحسب
المصادر ذاتها لم يتثنى لنا معرفه عدد
القتلى من قوات الحرس الايراني هذا
الاستهداف ليله البارحه سبقوا استهداف في
الثامن من الشهر الحالي لايضا قافله كانت
تحمل بحسب مصادر محليه جزء منها يحمل مواد
ومساعدات انسانيه وجزء اخر يحمل اسلحه
وصواريخ يتم نقلها الى الداخل السوري
مرورا من معبر القائم الحدودي مع العراق
ومن ثم الى جنوب سوريا بحسب المصادر ذاتها
نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 27 ضرب جويه امريكيه
استهدفت مواقع ومراكز تتمركز بها قوات
مواليه لايران او للحرس الثوري الايراني
في شمال شرق سوريا غالبيتها في دير الزور
وقرب الحدود مع العراق نتحدث عن مئات
الضربات الجويه اما بالمسيرات او بطائرات
اف 16 تابعه للتحالف الدولي منذ بدايه
الثوره السوريه منذ عام 2011
وبدا دخول القوات الايرانيه الى سوريا
وتشكيلها لطريق نقل بري من العراق من
الحدود السوريه العراقيه وحتى جنوب سوريا
بين الفينه والاخرى يحدث مثل هذه الضربات
وعاده ما تكون
لمواقع مواليه لايران او مراكز تابع الحرس
الثوري الايراني نعم شكرا لك ادهم ما اقول
الحسام مراسلنا من ادلب